how did you prepare for this room but I
was supposed to prepare
softer features David Peter Rob Lowe Rob
Lowe Oh probably David Smith because
David Spade doesn't look like he had
plastic surgery
hi I'm Melvin shock brother fraud if I
had a shoot he's gonna suck hey how long
is gonna suck I wouldn't want to be Rob
Lowe tonight I'm gonna you in the ass I
can't say that Kenny this is live what
we think of Rob Lowe's best Anwar for
old are um well everybody knows the big
one at the 1988 Democratic National
Convention I love that you couldn't
think
Ziya culture here I could see myself
laying them both down by the fire you
know what I mean
[Music]